c'était d'ailleurs franchement je suis
hyper content de pouce s'installent
ensemble et qu'on ait notre petit nid à
nous mêmes
cette télé non franchement c'est la
bonne taille pour mater des trucs où je
page de la console bref je range mes
affaires à chebba j'ai la flemme non mon
épouse ok je vais prendre une douche et
toi tu choisis un truc à regarder un
truc qui est juste et qui tuent des
figures montès
ça va être à moi
j'ai une super série c'est des coréens
qui sont enfermés et pour sortir il doit
games
met pas tous y patauger une série
documentaire énorme c'est sûr tueur en
série donc cette façon pas du tout non
n'importe quoi c'est sûr insectes c'est
sur un tueur en série dans une secte
mais c'est pas grave j'ai des films
également là là je devine qu'ils
cherchent star wars
il n'a pas du tout le monde et star trek
tôt contre c'est quasiment ce qui l'a
demandé je lui propose à 92% en même
temps tu recommandes tout à 92% spatiale
aussi vas-y gros malins proposent
biafine je suis sûr qu'elles n'ont pas
cet arrangement la vérité peut-être
peut-être pas chez paou lui botte son
impossible de trouver quoi que ce soit
on interface est tellement le bordel moi
c'est pas mon métier à la base un jeu
fait ça au be ok 9 euros ça peut me tuer
les garçons ne vous battez pas c'est moi
qui ai racheté star wars voilà j'ai
aussi racheté les simpson x-men pixar
mais aussi je veux des trucs cher acheté
j'ai aussi racheté marvel et surtout
j'ai tous les classiques avec lesquels
il a grandi parce qu'un petit star wars
sinon
ce
qui me semble mais c'était sur dix n'est
plus t'as que des trucs qu'on a vu revu
revue lors j'ai aussi plein de
nouveautés j'ai une série sur le chien
de là haut sur le demi frère de thor sur
la fourchette de toy story pour chette
de toy story mais tu t'écoutes un peu
dit ce n'est plus ça va être quoi la
prochaine fois le frère jumeau de
ratatouille la verrue plantaire de
vaiana le crypto et voilà j'ai racheté
les droits pour roland garros et la
ligue 1 bien sûr oui d'amiens vient
d'emménager schiste à neuf la ils vont
passer leurs premiers moments intimes
ils vont se battait un petit brest fc
nantes c'est vrai il faut pas que damien
oublie les plateformes françaises parce
qu'on a quand même game of thrones
walking dead succession que les c ries
et bigot quoi ouais oui vous êtes au
courant que edge bio ils vont arriver en
france ah non je n'étais pas augurer
tout leur catalogue
dans la merde qu'est ce qui nous reste
c'est pas entendu un bruit de mer la
grèce et salto l'aller tout oubli c'est
la plateforme la de france télé m6 tf1
donné aux éléments rosé ou marek salto
dit ouais t'as quoi en stock genre je
propose est peut-être qu'à peut-être
marleau
il me tue le concarnois les
français me font marrer cutter
bonjour mick hannah l'enchanté attendu
puis quand d'amis la maille canal là bas
depuis que son père lui prête son compte
ça sert à ça la famille c'est de la
triche d'ailleurs j'ai une offre qui
vous comprend tous sauf prime prime
tubes en revanche bombe en eau
je crois que damien oublier mot de passe
et son père doit dormir fait chier à bas
à l'est d'amiens même choisi en plus
voilà un petit film d'action à
l'ancienne
patronne titre je vous l'avais dit je
vérifie rien moi je paie mes films il se
démerde sous dit pas sous-titré babolat
elle apprendra l'anglais c'est très bien
mais je crois que tamir rajoute une
nouvelle plate forme c'est toujours
gratuit
bonjour apple tv + faut hausser ça ne va
pas besoin d'une plateforme en plus à
des téléphones et des ordinateurs liés à
la base on n'est plus vraiment à la page
j'ai des séries telles que ce morning
show tu es de l'aso où une série avec
jason momoa way
et c'est tout c'est tout j'ai quand même
jennifer aniston steve carell chris
evans et justin timberlake des dizaines
de récompenses pour chaque série je
pense que damian et sa compagne préfère
la qualité à la quantité après j'ai jean
ainsi que park 2 mais je trouve plus le
rat c'est moi qui l'ait vu passer les
dents de la mer mais ces mêmes
réalisateurs et puis c'est une bestiole
qui bouffent des gens donc c'est leur
pareil je vous recommande à 92 points je
veux pas attirer l'attention mais moi
j'ai recherche appartement ou maison en
avant première après faut aimer stéphane
plaza un petit film d'horreur sinon
alors là c'est bien ça je dis j'aime
beaucoup la bce c'est payant dans la
gelée mais b on voit donc tu vas pas
quoi donc j'ai beau c'est amiens damiens
a bien vieilli six tours gratuits s'est
dit heureux roule dans rent on te voit
l'homme il trottinait fait comme s'il
n'existait pas là continuent à augmenter
les prix aussi c'est bien pour mon
business n'augmente pas les prix on
parle de nos deux flics je crois en
cours moi je ne demande pas à les prix
sauf une fois où chaque fois j'écoute la
messale tentait un fail ou c'est fou oui
bages augmente un peu les prix de temps
en temps mais chaque plus 2014 on verra
dans quelques années vos prières
n'explique je suis la plus plus
longtemps que toi je suis toujours
gratos d'accord donc désormais il ya
youtube nous parlons de vrais contenus
des séries ou des films un pad et
challenge ou des courts métrages de
cyprien pardon les blocs doute de l'ena
situation cinq saisons 30 un épisode où
les vacances des croûtons des millions
de spectateurs gratuit montcuq youtube a
on a vu le nombre de pubs que tu mets à
montevideo la petit tout et 3g comptait
pas de ma faute si damien c'est un gros
rat là il veut pas payer youtube premium
est embrouillée j'ai tout à tuer vient
d'amiens même des séries en vo avec les
sous-titrés tout sûr tu trouves ça d'un
claquement de doigts
bon qu'il faut remplacer les points
d'interrogation par les apostrophes et
le car est lassé et les sous titres sont
décalés n'importe quoi
enfin à part ça c'est du vol du vol s'il
te plaît my canal tu as vu le prix que
tu coûtes bon attendez un apple tv plus
il coûte cher aussi neflix a augmenté de
prix pendant qu'on parle aux lebastard
annonce à 20 personnes avaient remarqué
avant vous en parliez la rappelle
que j'ai tout le catalogue de la fox
ainsi que star julien omar vais là mais
j'ai quand même plus de 4000 films et
ses usines et je rajoute un switch pour
l'autre à toi tu aimais plus et là du
tout comment réparer une machine à laver
est comme ça un petit chat mais laissez
moi
non mais le premier mois et est gratuit
et elle choisit quoi du coup eh ben je
m'étais dit que peut-être
enfin peut-être un blog c'est ma source
en salle futsal a pas mal ça non
ben je sais pas lecteur principal s'est
pas terminé mais il est pas mal et
lectrices elle a quelque chose non ça va
le croire c'est une histoire d'amour
c'est pas trop niono j'espère oui un peu
mais bon ça marche bien j'ai vu que le
début c'est vraiment super je passais
d'après
c'est par un très gros budget ouais non
non mais j'avais vu parce que les décors
sont pas dans dix ans c'est l'histoire
qui me plaît bien
sache achète directement moi j'achète le
web elle supprime le forum le fouquet's
bio j'ai transformé lui en super mutants
est leur super héroïne ça fera quatre
volets c'est le moi j'ai rien depuis
[Musique]